KRISTEN O'LEARY:
All right, everyone.
Thank you for joining.
And welcome to Migrating
Cassandra Workloads
to Cloud Bigtable.
Brief introductions.
My name is Kristen O'Leary.
I'm a developer
relations engineer.
And I focus on Bigtable
client libraries.
BILLY JACOBSON: And
I'm Billy Jacobson.
I'm also a developer
relations engineer
focusing on Cloud Bigtable,
sample code, and tutorials.
So Kristen's going to kick
things off in this presentation
by talking about why you
might want to migrate
to Bigtable from Cassandra.
And different application
structures you might have that
are fairly common in Cassandra.
Then with all those applications
and potential applications
there, she's going to walk you
through how you would migrate
each of those to Bigtable.
Then once that's done,
I'm going to walk you
through all the code
and sample resources
we have available to make that
process as easy as possible.
So Kristen, why don't
you kick things off?
KRISTEN O'LEARY: Thanks, Billy.
So we're going to
start with reasons
why you may want to migrate
from Cassandra to Bigtable.
So we're going to focus on
just two different examples.
The first is maybe
you're currently
struggling to maintain
availability, durability,
and performance of your current
existing distributed database.
So some more examples
include maybe you're
struggling with
stability at scale.
Or maybe there's just too much
operational load on your SREs.
Or you're just generally
dealing with overhead
of managing replication,
repair, and things
like garbage collection.
A second point could be you may
want to move up the tech stack
and spend less time
and money on things
like managing the different
complexities of a distributed
database.
So examples here
include maybe you
want to reduce the
total cost of operation
of your infrastructure
and do things
that were different
than before and things
that weren't possible before.
So now we're going to walk
into some technical steps.
So of course step
0 here is you need
to plan for your migration.
So before you dive into a
migration from Cassandra
to Bigtable, it's really
important to deep dive
into Cassandra use cases and
gain a better understanding
of how Bigtable and
how they're the same
and how they're different.
You should do things like map
concepts, schemas, and queries
from Cassandra to
Cloud Bigtable.
A quick tip--
Cassandra primary
key, you can look
at as the same as equal
as a Bigtable row key.
That's a great
starting assumption.
Billy is going to
talk about that later.
But that's a great
place to start
when you're looking and thinking
about this type of migration.
Next, we're going to
walk through an example
of a migration flow.
So step 1, you can look
into doing dual writes.
So you're currently
obviously writing
into your Cassandra database.
Now you want to
try and write both
into Cassandra and Bigtable.
So any new data will
go into both databases.
Step 2, now that you have
new data in Cloud Bigtable,
you want to copy over the old
data from Cassandra into it.
So you want to do
copying of existing data
from Cassandra into
Cloud Bigtable.
Step 3, option, you can
compare between the two.
So make sure that your data is
consistent between Cassandra
and Bigtable.
Step 4, redirect you reads.
So we're writing into Bigtable.
And now that the data
should be equivalent to what
we had in the
Cassandra database,
we can also start
reading into Bigtable.
So redirect your reads from
Cassandra to Cloud Bigtable.
Step 5, stop your dual writes.
So now we're basically using
Bigtable to read and to write.
No need to dual write anymore.
So you can turn off the writing
into your Cassandra database
and only focus on Bigtable.
And Step 6, now you're done.
And you can
decommission Cassandra.
So next up is migration paths.
We're going to talk through
four different migration paths
that you may encounter and
how to proceed with them.
So here are some examples of
common Cassandra migration
paths.
And they each have different
migration strategies.
Again, we'll look at them
more in detail on each side.
We're going to start with
batch load, global serve.
So you may have an
application where
you load data into one region.
And then you may want to
replicate the data out to other
serving regions.
So in this example, the first
thing we would want to do
is rewrite our batch
jobs to support Bigtable.
So this job that does
all of the writing,
you now want to support
Bigtable as well as Cassandra.
Secondly, you want to rewrite
your API to support Bigtable.
So instead of just
writing to Cassandra, now
we're writing to Bigtable.
And now we want to start
changing API to do things
like read as well.
Step 3, you want to run
your batch jobs in parallel
to load the data, both into
Cassandra and Bigtable.
And then finally,
once you're done,
and once you feel that
data is equivalent,
you can release to switch
your API layer from Cassandra
to Bigtable.
So you'll see here
in the diagram,
first we had just the
Cassandra instance.
And now we're writing
to Bigtable as well
to serve the end users.
So next step is when
downtime is acceptable.
This is another common
application instance
where your application you may
be able to accept some downtime
and have a maintenance window.
So this is an example
of how you can do
the migration during that time.
So first up, you want to
stop writing to Cassandra
during your migration window.
And then you just want to do a
big batch copy from Cassandra
to Bigtable.
And so once you've done that,
the data should be equivalent.
And you can optionally
compare to ensure
that your data is correct.
And then switch over your
serving layer entirely
to Bigtable.
So now your API will
talk to Bigtable instead.
And then you want to
decommission Cassandra.
So you can see here
in the diagram.
We've now switched
over the API layer
to talk to Bigtable as well.
Next is online
with time to live.
So this is another
common workload
where let's say you have
something like a cache or user
sessions where you have data
that eventually will expire.
So we'll use that
to our benefit here.
So that, first up,
of course, we want
to rewrite our code again
so that we're writing data
into both Cassandra
and Bigtable.
So now we're getting
all of our new data
into the table as well.
And then you want to wait until
your time to live expires.
So once your data that was
only in Cassandra has expired,
the two databases
should be equivalent.
Again, you can do things
like do asynchronous
callbacks to verify
that the data is
consistent between the two.
And then finally you can
decommission Cassandra.
So again, it's the
same diagram, we've
written to both
Cassandra and Bigtable,
and then eventually
do the time to live.
Both sets will
become equivalent.
And last but not least, we have
online with persistent data.
This is a workload
that's user-facing,
semi-transactional, can't
accept any type of downtime.
So how do we work in that case?
So you want to, again,
rewrite your API layer
to read and write
to both systems.
And then ensure there's managed
consistency in the API layer
just in case something is down.
You want to batch copy and back
fill your data into Bigtable
because, again, you can't
accept any downtime.
And then you want to do
asynchronous callbacks
between the two--
again, and then we
keep saying this--
to make sure that your data
is consistent and equivalent.
And then once you're
satisfied with the consistency
of your data, you can
shut down Cassandra.
So we've talked about a
lot of different situations
and examples.
Now Billy is going to take us
through some of the actual code
that you will use if you want
to do a migration from Cassandra
to Bigtable.
BILLY JACOBSON: Thank
you so much, Kristen.
We've got a lot of
starting points from there.
So from those paths
you were going to take,
there are two major
aspects to your migration--
migrating your queries and
doing your batch data migration.
So let's first look
at migrating queries.
And if you're using Cassandra
or any kind of database,
you have a lot of queries
you're going to want to migrate.
So you're managing your
tables with queries,
any kinds of garbage
collection with queries.
You're writing your data.
You're reading data.
And you might also
have analysts that
need to perform
table-wide analytics
and are more
comfortable with SQL
than some of the
programming languages
that we have client
libraries for.
So I'm going to walk you
through a bunch of examples.
And they are all available
later in this codelab,
Cloud Bigtable for
Cassandra users.
You can learn the
basics of migrating
a lot of these queries.
And all the code that's in these
slides will be available there.
So don't feel that you
need to pause the video
to figure out what the code is.
You can find the link later.
So let's look at
an example database
just to make things
a little bit more
concrete through these examples.
So we're storing data about
mobile devices in a time
series.
So we have information
about their cellular plan,
how much data each phone has,
if it's connected to the Wi-Fi,
connected to a cell tower, and
which operating system it's on.
And you might have a
lot more data in here.
We also are storing the device
type, a device ID, and the date
that that data is stored on.
And we could store
that in the row.
But also we've upgraded
it into our row key
because this is where we
are doing our queries from.
This is very similar to
our Cassandra primary key.
So all your queries
for Bigtable are going
to be based on your row key.
Kristin mentioned
earlier your primary key
can be pretty much
translated into your row key
by just concatenating the
important parts of it.
So here we have device
type, device ID, and date.
And Bigtable queries
are based on row gets,
based on the row key
and row range scans,
based on the row keys as well.
So these features
are really going
to determine which
queries are going
to be the most performant.
So to get started
with Bigtable, you're
probably going to use our
command line utility, which is
similar to the Cassandra shell.
And this is called the CBT tool.
Here I'm showing you how to
create a table with the CBT
tool.
And you'll notice
with Cassandra,
you're used to defining
all the columns in advance,
defining your primary key.
And we don't do
that in Bigtable.
We just defined the table
name and any column families.
And you can define your
garbage collection rules
at the column family level.
So the CBT tool is great
for creating your tables,
getting everything set up.
But you can also use it
for reading and writing
data, deleting data,
managing your app profiles,
managing your
garbage collection.
And if you have any scripts
for database automation
that you have set up,
maybe using Cassandra shell
or anything like
that, the CBT tool
is a great way to
just swap those out
if you're switching
over to Bigtable.
But for your application,
you're probably
going to want to use one
of our client libraries.
We have our client libraries
available in eight programming
languages.
Go, Java, Python, Node.js,
just to name to few.
And we have documented
all the different ways
you're probably going to
want to use Bigtable there.
So we're going to just
look at the Java client.
But again, all those
other client libraries
will be well-documented with
examples similar to these.
So here if we're writing
data, in Cassandra
you're used to doing an insert.
You're going to specify the
columns and their values.
Where, Bigtable, we do
writes as a mutation.
So we'll take our row
key and create a mutation
from that where we set a
cell's value so the cells are
in intersection of the row key,
the column family, and column.
And then we provide
a value for it.
And you'll also note here,
we're providing a timestamp.
Bigtable will let you
store multiple values
at different versions in a cell.
And you can use that as part
of your time series storage
strategy.
And with garbage
collection, you can
determine how many
versions are kept
or how old those versions are.
So one of the parts
of your migration
is going to be dual
writes potentially.
So to do that,
you're going to pick
your client library of choice.
And then alongside any
of your insertions,
you're going to
create a mutation
to match that alongside of it.
So now let's look at
two select statements.
Here, we're just
selecting one row,
because we're selecting
on all the parts
of the primary keyword.
So we've got the device type,
the device ID, and a date.
And in Bigtable,
we're just going
to translate that into a
row key by concatenating
all that information.
And here we're using
the pound symbol
to separate each
piece of information.
But you can really use
any symbol you want.
So we take our row key and
then we just perform a get.
And you can do whatever you
want with the data from there.
So if you wanted to verify that
your data had been migrated
correctly, you could query
Cassandra and Bigtable
at the same time, wrap those in
an asynchronous callback block,
and then log any
deviations that you've
got until everything is
matching or you've sort
out any of those errors.
So you can also do
this for multiple rows.
Here, we're scanning for all
the dates or all the dates
after 2019, or just 2020 at this
point, for a specific phone.
So with Bigtable, we can
do a prefix scan for that.
We're going to, instead
of doing the full row,
we just take part
of the row key.
So we're taking the device
type phone and the device ID,
which is 4C41, or
whatever it is.
And then we're just
taking the year
because all the data for
the device that's in 2020
will have that as its
prefix for their scan.
So we pass that
prefix to the scan.
And then we can get
all the rows for that.
And you can use this
in multiple ways.
So let's say you want to get
all the data for 2020 and 2019,
you can create a scan which
is two prefixes at once,
and get all that
data back at once.
And you perform queries
and create ways to do that.
But if you're going to have
a little bit more nuance
in your queries than what
the row key can provide,
maybe just for one-off
queries or you're
trying to learn new
things about your data,
you're going to use filters.
And this is very similar to
allow filtering in Cassandra.
So we have timestamp
filtering, value filtering.
You could do row key regexes
if part of the row key
is going to help you out.
But again, like Cassandra
with allow filtering,
you don't want to let it
just do full table scans.
So we recommend that you have
a range as part of that query
or do a prefix and just
limit how much data
you're going to be
scanning with that filter.
And then a final option
for migrating your queries
to Bigtable is to use
Bigtable as an external data
source on a BigQuery.
And this is just easy.
It is really easy to do.
You set up configuration file
to translate some of your data
into BigQuery.
And then you can do
table-wide analytics on it
with a SQL-like language.
So this is a lot more performant
for your table-wide analytics.
You can save some of
the data after you
query it to Bigtable to
hand that to an analyst
if they just want to
draw on a lot of queries
on the same set of data.
Or we actually see
a lot of customers
write data to
Bigtable and BigQuery.
And they use the
data warehousing
features of BigQuery
and the speed and QPS
that Bigtable provides
as a database.
So that's all about how
to migrate your queries.
But most of the scenarios
that Kristin went through
include a batch data migration.
And we know this
can be intimidating.
You have a lot of data.
You don't want to lose that.
You want to make sure
it all stays in sync.
So we've made it super easy
with our bulk load tool.
This is going to run
on Cloud Dataflow,
our managed and hosted
data Apache Beam runner.
It does an automatic
schema conversion for you.
It will copy the data.
And there's no coding needed.
You'll just pass in
your configuration file
with the tables, key spaces,
and server information.
And then you can run it
with the command line.
And what's great is
this is all open source.
So if you want to take
our bulk load tool
and make it work from some more
of your specific requirements,
feel free to do
And on Apache Beam,
we have the Cassandra
I/O Bigtable I/O,
and even BigQuery
I/O connectors.
So you can write
any pipelines that
connect these three to
make whatever dataflow
is going to work best for you.
So now you understand why
you might want to migrate,
how to determine the path to
get from Cassandra to Bigtable,
you can do your dual writes,
stated verifications,
and your batch data migration.
So what are you
going to do next?
If you're an
existing customer, we
recommend that you connect
with one of your account teams
to get started.
They'll help connect you to a
lot of the resources we have.
But if you're not,
you can check out
some of these links we've got.
Here's a link to the
codelab I mentioned earlier.
So you can get started on
seeing how your queries are
going to migrate.
And you can even check out
a talk from Cloud Next 2019
where Spotify discusses how
they migrated from Cassandra
to Bigtable using a lot of
the techniques and tools
from this talk.
Thank you so much for attending.
And happy migrations.